[Music]
how many love stories actually end up
going well after the last page in real
life there's no final scene where
everything gets neatly wrapped up the
story just keeps going until it doesn't
where does all this come from you know
how do we come out of that
into this
at some point the stuff inside Stars
becomes conscious
every single one of them has a story and
sometimes somehow for whatever reason
you get a chance to become part of them
even if just for a moment
what's going on why am I here
people seem to always forget what it's
like to fall in love and how it feels
when you hit the ground
sup seriously I can't run anymore
you can leave me here you know I'd
understand
couples break up every day for all sorts
of reasons just consider this a very
strange one
what are you saying
I don't know what I believe at this
point life is too complicated and absurd
to believe anything but it's also too
complicated and absurd
to not care about anything
[Music]
foreign